c'est non pierre desproges ça fait
penser à ça fait penser à un proverbe
chinois qui dit que les pauvres faut
leur apprendre à pêcher c'est plus utile
que de celle ordonnée
oui c'est un peu pour ça je le
restaurant du coeur je me mets pas tous
dans la salle du coeur il a beau
spectacle vous avez une phrase assez dur
sur les pauvres des riches ou enfin non
non je dis que si on me laissait à moi
le pouvoir
j'aurai une proposition à faire c'est à
dire que j'aimerais qu'en temps de paix
les pauvres le droit de pardon non quand
on paie les riches le droit de prendre
la sueur au front les pauvres et qu'en
temps de guerre les pauvres aient le
droit de prendre la place des riches ou
feront également aux confins des buts
programme voté le programme qui est
intéressant on va se retrouver dans un
instant sur le bien venir jusqu'à joie
place huit plaqués nous une interview
dans cette maison c'est là ça se passe
là vous vers les aiguilles étaient là la
semaine dernière vous avez apprécié je
sais bien des proches ça sent le pauvre
encore bonjour merci d'être venu avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes malade
aujourd'hui
oui j'ai une côte cassée c'est pas grave
quand c'est arrivé au service esso tu
manges que s'étant enfin c'est j'ai
tourné
une fausse pub pour les nuls ces gens
dont on parle trop des arrêtés
certainement pas il s'agissait de une
publicité pour la bière c'est à dire on
l'avait freehand et myriam isker qui est
la réalisatrice et pris des images du
stade du heysel et ça s'est terminé par
une bagarre de supporters jeudi de
ramasser un un coup de matraque un peu
sur le dos et à la fin je disais si sur
les cadavres du sl je disais en buvant
une canette de bière on peut rester
actifs après une bonne vieille boîte tu
as très bien moi j'ai été puni par le
bon dieu ça c'est une côte et chrétiens
qui revient de face et la fiction
vieille histoire
alors on vous connaît bien à travers vos
gaga travers tout ce que vous faites
depuis depuis des années maintenant
l'avouent vous donner en spectacle
travers toute la france
bon c'est pas bien qui vous êtes moi je
suis toujours demandé ce qui ce qui vous
déclenchez d'où venaient à votre
écriture d'où venaient vos idées vous
êtes un ancien journaliste vous rajoutez
un peu journalistes dans votre approche
comment ça se passe quand j'ai toujours
écrit j'ai dû tout écrit dans un canard
ou dans un autre ça m'est jamais arrivé
de rester un mois sans fait un peu pitié
un journal aujourd'hui préparer des
sketches commente en voyant les gens
travaillant en grattant jeu pas de
deux règles
je m'attaque par exemple je suis fâché
que les objets je suis vraiment
dyslexique et gauchers contrariés
je vois que c'est d'attraper une chemise
dans un placard je fais tomber tout je
me venge tous les soirs sur scène qu un
sketch sur les cintres ou ja tacle
haineusement le sainte qui est l'ennemi
de pour moi un des ennemis avec sabatier
un des ennemis de l'humanité
alors faut quand même dire qu'il était
un spectacle j'avais moi vous êtes vous
est formidablement brutale et c'est
presque jamais brutalité du timide là
vous irez vraiment pas de même dans les
pays où même une grande pudeur là dedans
mais ça fait quand même très pudique
c'est une façon brassens disait qu'une
façon de montrer son cul pour cacher son
coeur qui était une marque depuis 2
heures 20 le disait mieux que moi en ce
moment
il sait je crois que c'est comme ça ça
me gêne beaucoup de parler de moi ce
n'est même pas voir les trous 9 sur 16
chacun en prend pour son grade les
intellos à prennent pas la tête
oui je peux marquer le plus d 1 des
looks les cultivateurs et tous les
intellos vous dites par exemple si je me
souviens bien vous dites que les
intellos ils sont courageux à moins de
dix mille kilomètres de là il ya des non
je parle pas des intellos là je pars les
artistes engagés
je me situe comme artiste dégagé et
jeu par rapport à un artiste engagé qui
osent critiquer pinochet à moins de
10000 km de santiago
ce genre de choses que c'est peut-être
une lâcheté de pas s'engager mais j'aime
bien je crois que c'est bien d'être dans
doute oui vous après moi je suis pas sûr
que la droite se soit bien je suis pas
sûr que la gauche se soit bien je
considère comme un devoir civique de ne
pas voter
alors vous en parlez vous apprenez
également à marguerite duras par exemple
que vous aimez pas des masses de la
passion c'est à dire que je ne comprends
pas tout lu ça m'énerve ça m'énerve
c'est certes un bouquin j'arrive mai
mais enfin je précise nous aussi parce
qu'il fait naître dans ses spectacles
que marguerite duras n'a pas écrit que
des conneries
elle en a aussi filmé ouvert et c'est
très clair vous la voulez traiter d'
apologistes sénile des infanticides
ruraux bah oui il a fait un plaqué dans
le monde
allag arrivée dans libé où ils se font
toujours plus calé ce qui est risible
c'est celui qu'il faut avoir souvent à
ce moment ci vivait en principe jusqu'à
voir l'autre bout de bras oui et vous
vous êtes en train de faire vous aimé
terminer un entier almanach vermot alors
ça c'est pourquoi des proches
ah oui là je suis en train de définir
nos éditeurs voulaient pas que j'en
parle trop vite il
il avait peur que que la rue où se bâtit
apprennent à écrire pour faire le même
mêlant les baisses accusées moi ce geste
inélégance police anglaise dans votre
genre non mais non c'était un peu de
fatigue et c'est pour voir si la coupe
marc hé oui c'est en allemagne qu'il se
plie carrément l'almanach des proches de
responsables dans lequel il y aura des
dictons lors de dicton c'est grave ce
sera un véritable almanach c'est à dire
qu'il ya sur la page de droite il y aura
ce meynier avec
l'adie mardi au lieu de mettre le sein
de la semaine mettra le conte de la
semaine je pense que c'est très vague
ça va de mitterrand chirac en passant
par j'oubliais je sais plus touchées les
utilisez pas de sens peut-être des gens
qui sont pas évidents il yal alagna
poivre d'arvor qui est un ami je coupe
les critiquons l'habitat sanaryenne les
idées les dictant c'est quoi avaler
dictant ses dictons j'ai inventé mais
dans le style des bd des dictons
classique et n'a que j'aime beaucoup
bien qu'il faut deux mois c'est
complètement vrai c'est à trop manger sa
mère on devient orphelin voilà des
victoires à la pensée du jour il y aura
ça s'est passé il ya cinq ans il ya dix
ans il ya vingt ans comme comme comme le
verbe haut exactement c'est une copie je
pense d'ailleurs que le verrou va me
faire interdire parce que ça va
ressembler énormément au vermont vous
suivez la politique de travaux sonore
intéresse pas dû lui non pas du tout
c'est à dire si ça m'intéresse de très
loin pour traire jeu je vois pas la
différence entre bar et mitterrand 6-6
savoir la politique de prêt je vois pas
pour moi c'est le même qui fait les deux
par rapport à ce qui serait si on
réfléchit au bilan de la droite est au
bilan de la gauche s'est engagé expliqué
ya pas longtemps député maire de saint
nazaire qui dès qu'il met très bien
reçue il me saouler la gueule après
parce que le tacle de grâce à bonneville
et il me disait quand même nous la
gauche je dis qu'est-ce qui vous ai fait
plus que la droite et il m'a dit quand
même on a supprimé la peine de mort
je dis oui d'accord mais ça concerne qui
combien de personnes mais savoir si
mitterrand se présente je présente pas
vous en fichez j'espère que je me passe
le meulage espère qu'il ne présente pas
et en plus il a atteint l'âge de la
prostate faut arrêter là
mais beauxis présente ça m'est
complètement égal
vraiment ça changera pas grand chose
merci car des reportages américaine il
ya un détail je peux me permettre vous
après ce qui me fait penser quand même
quoi que je dise que je m'intéresse pas
la politique de prêt que mitterrand va
se représenter c'est que on l'a un peu
oublié les son premier acte politique
quand il a pris le fauteuil de giscard
s'étaient tissés autour de l'elysée pour
délimiter son territoire et ce à une
fouine qui fait ça s'en va puis après
écoute et merci d'avoir répondu si
franchement année ligne ont permis aux
proches
on aurait peut-être dans deux ans si
vous voulez on va voir on va voir ce qui
serait bien utile à gauche parce que la
gauche laisse dire ce genre de péri aux
jambes aux gens de droite ça al'avantage
de la gauche sur la droite et ça c'est
tout votre spectacle qui est dans l'ès
effectivement pour personne fait peu mon
nom
[Musique]